Tracy this house ours is so beautiful
like I know you have like 19 guest
bedrooms and a bowling alley and it
areum's my office it was inspired by
vito corleone same color and everything
I was gonna say that it looks like Vito
Corleone's like where Morticia to come
and say can I be a friend Godfather
have you taken a hit in the stock market
financially I mean it's very bad out
there I've got all my money my money's
under my pillow I'm old school black
person right in other words my mother
got my money at her fittings so in other
words you're not affected really like
the rest of the world with coronavirus
because you were smart are you able to
feed these sharks you'll have some of
the largest fish tanks in America laughs
the last night baby
really I'm telling you Walmart gave me a
lifetime supply to all the people I'm
good look at this chain let me see my
thing that's a moray eel over there yeah
I I like that my office you see how big
this thing is
yeah that's a hundred gallons and who is
feeding the fish in other words you've
got an aquarium I feed them every day
and where are you getting deliveries of
all this fish
I have stockpile of food baby you're
digging deep - I love that this right is
the law you got the man this look like a
training bra can't cool right Tracy you
can't you can't make that mask into a
training bra in the ghetto my aunt she
got a 66 double D's right night there's
no money to get the husband demands so
she cut up a broad she got to take kids
she covered the hole all the kids how is
your business being affected in other
words Tracy as a stand-up comedian I'm
not worried about corona okay not not
you
huzi I'm worried about another Walmart
truck you think you think lightning can
hit twice
I want Amazon this time I'm not on that
turnpike everyday i'ma keep my mind
always should be which is gonorrhea you
Mona and we go outbreak of God real
Robin I look like money right Tracy that
hairdo is fantastic did you go to the
barber shop in the middle of the
coronaviruses shop in salon in my house
you have a barber there I got a barber
shop
it must state-of-the-art your might but
Tracy it was mine when it cut my hair
you should see his ways oh look at this
wow you are a handsome guy Hospital you
have an indoor basketball court yeah
this house is 30,000 square feet man 29
and a half man I endure movie theater I
got a hole in Ali
I got a David buses in here okay
you walk around man you see so much fun
things for you and your wife to do in
here man so we look good my daughter
I'll do this homeschooling and you do
that yeah me and my wife we take turns
homeschooling it's hard what subjects do
you teach I teach her you know black
history oh I would start history right
[Music]
Tracey you got a tape you homeschooling
that kid and let me see that I want to
see what's going on over there
you be like [ __ ] the last og dis
muhfucka need to get a GED program right
Tracy I love you heaven Ali really the
GED program in his house I'll be on it